o relato diz pessoal daqui quem fala eu
dar que sejam muito bem vindos já mais
um vídeo e os tragos de que faz next e
chandra que duas personagens principais
deste julga os pontos bobos é de
estrelas e lula você já sabe há intenção
nem isto vai borrar o leque é o dólar
ainda que eu estou na minha tela toda
suja lenta estão estão microfone e tocam
lights
ok temos duas portas entende que esta
parte do meio que eu não sei o que é que
este botão do do herói
o casal que quer que aconteça ou por ser
uma contagem a bomba vai aumentar
não sei o que aconteceu mês fecha a
porta estava expondo uma usando calça
quadrada faixa a faixa foi um barulho
forte
não é só não funciona já viu câmeras
hoje tem esquema era já não tinha visto
ainda o bicho e iêmen eu não sei em que
lugar e este não parece nada eu quero
uma casa de banho
temos aqui a parte das escadas o tac os
planos bava eo zé e os da estrela acho
que era melhor eu voltar pra minha sala
né eu acho que ataque o irã nas portas
não ser a luz não tá aqui ninguém mas
junto ao ouvir um barulho muito estranho
aqui meu e não possuindo para que serve
este botão ok só 14 e 20 da manhã eu
ainda não fiz [ __ ] nenhuma
já são quatro da manhã a monstanto
julgar é um beque vocês andaram lá eu
posso mexer nisto eu possa ativar a
ventilação meu da foto
eu consigo ataque olha a primeira festa
não acho que é que acha que está muito
perto de mim estou vivo andar mil caiu
nesta cama escola e passei a noite
tá bom tá boa tá um eu não consegui
ainda para que seja neste botão ou vai
vai o verão traz em si deve ser por
cancelar o que eu não sei o que é que a
obra vai va deve ser do tipo mandar as
ruas já washington iniciar e eu acho que
para lá
não não é o sistema não espera espera
apagar as luzes não eu só consegui
fechar uma porta toda vez que meu deus
meu deus foi acabar agora
agora você quiser as portas porque eu
jogo tudo o que é isso consigo isso vai
apanhar né não sei o que será que ele
entrou querendo se passou aqui e de uma
voz ajuda pessoal tudo contar com isso é
se vocês souberem de alguma coisa se
vocês souberem como ex jogas viram já em
um dos vídeos digão pessoal nos
comentários como é que eu vou conseguir
passar esta noite ou na segunda noite
mas eu quero chegar pelo menos a 30 a
quarta eu não sei se está mesmo até a
sexta noite mas pronto eu quero pelo
menos avançar até a terceira
vamos lá ver as câmeras uns putos vamos
superar direta para a liga e tentar
travar o óscar mas não o contrário
bogotá é isso mesmo tom ao contrário
porque os postos em tudo do lado inverso
versão ainda está aqui eu tava na minha
porta ainda falou que bicho é que homem
que bishek o ps o cara que vai embora e
não saía ser eu não sei para que serve o
hospital overdrive mais uma música que é
ou vai ver que a nossa memória vamos
fechar essa porta porque foi a equipe x
men primeira classe o que é qiu bo
transformou-se num tem em carne
pendurada man card e expresse um talho
já não toco esperar este jogo
lula né
olha aí ninguém respondeu após agora não
consigo usar estoque então para vou
pagar a luz e vou usar isso a tam já tô
primeiro chama eu foi que houvesse outra
vez
estranho expresso marinha macaco o que é
aquilo
estamos nesse quadro não é pessoal
faltam duas horas para conseguir passar
esta noite poderá se fotografam este
jogo como é que eu faço isto meu é noite
2 e este até difícil aqui os
responsáveis parece ilustrar esta porta
ok temos duas portas fechadas porque nos
querem roubar dos dois lados mesmo
relação passou por aqui é porque eu não
cheguei a integração eo x 15 de vida que
a ventilação que se avançou nas suas
portas fechem as portas lançou ainda não
conseguiu fechar aquela para apagar a
luz
ok é eu acho que não eu acho que você
apanhar vou ser apanhado agora eu estava
cansado para minha sala eu ouvi lo este
barulho ela andar
não sei se devia abrir as portas ao
tentar instalar
eu não sei por que eu saiba ainda mais
pronto elas pela ventilação exato fecha
exatamente o ok ok ok ainda bem que fui
ver a minha evolução
eu acho que sim eu não sei se eu passou
agora não porque ache né
agora eu não saí eu não eu não sei o que
eu vou fazer história por ser agora
eleita respondeu à esquerda mas a porta
e outro vai passar além ou seja precisa
pagar ao luxo de fechar aquela porta e
vou tentar fazer isso com cuidado e com
calma não aparece
parece que o país entrou no mar para
definir isso sozinho aqui é o país em
que o pai se trata piano a eu acho que
pela primeira vez vou conseguir ficar
até as 5 horas
o rápido ataque
o filho da mãe daniel passou eu passou
eu possuo
foi só a porta vai ao ew passou eu vim e
um filme ou como é que é possível então
é isso pessoal vamos ficar porque o
espírito e espero que vocês tenham
gostado e não consegui passar desta
segunda noite vocês viram este jogo é
difícil pode ter um fluxo muito lobo já
sabem quanto o vosso comentário queremos
lá e conseguir passar este explique por
que serva [ __ ] do botão que eu não sei
ainda fique bem e até a próximo